hallo und herzlich willkommen hier aus
der tanzschule elmayer in wien auch im
digitalen zeitalter ist es notwendig in
persönlichen kontakt gute umgangsformen
an den tag zu legen
unter dem motto umgangsformen 4.0
möchten wir euch gemeinsam mit professor
thomas schäfer elmayer einige tipps dazu
präsentieren
herr professor herzlichen dank dass sie
sich die zeit für uns nehmen
über welche themen werden wir heute mehr
heran ich freue mich dass wir heute über
dieses thema reden können das geht ja
eigentlich nur um allgemeinwissen bei
diesen regeln und wir wollen heute
zunächst einmal den beginn jedes
treffens besprechen das grüßen das
begrüßen dann auch wie man einer dame
korrekt einen blumenstrauß überreicht
vielleicht auch dem handkuss dann wie
man mit einer reinhören person durch
eine türe geht ist auch eine ein
interessantes thema und natürlich auch
die tischmanieren wollen wir besprechen
herr professor dankeschön wir freuen uns
auf die erklärungen die erste folge sind
sie am montag den 13 jänner hier auf
diesem kanal